brought to you by the PlayStation
original series powers watch the series
premiere for free on March 10th at
playstation com hey guys it is most of
today my name is Jess McDonald and
you're watching James bunnies dragon age
inquisition of getting a massive patch
so if you haven't finished to get here's
all the good stuff in store for you the
impending patch five is slated to be the
largest and most impactful update since
the game's launch it features a bunch of
improvements to gameplay and gain
stability as well as adding party
storage functionality to the undercroft
at sky hole the patch is coming to all
platforms although the toggle Mouse look
feature is coming only to PC as you'd
imagine and it's still a work in
progress you can check out the full list
of things that are changing and
improving in our story on gamespot next
up we may have a new release date for
avalanches Mad Max game although it
seems that the last gen console versions
won't be coming at all the upcoming game
from Just Cause creator based on the hit
australian film series will only be
arriving on xbox one ps4 and PC
Avalanche explains to Game Informer that
the xbox 360 and ps3 versions were
cancelled so that the team could focus
on the current gen admission Mad Max was
originally scheduled to land in 2014 but
was delayed to an undetermined time now
videogamer.com are reporting that the
game will land in early September of
this year thoroughly state for Metal
Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain is a
mystery no longer although it probably
didn't come out the way that Konami
would have preferred the phantom pain
will be arriving on sep tember first of
this year it's presumed that the
countdown which ends tomorrow is going
to reveal the date to the world but a
video which showed the release date
leaked onto IGN ahead of time as
discovered by neogaf member nibel as
always nothing stays secret from the
internet for long let me know down in
the comments if you're more excited for
Mad Max or metal gear
cyber offense and pain and why you can
add the game spot where we've got news
on a massive battlefield for updates and
load the GDC 2015 content that is it for
me today I have a bunch more news for
you same time tomorrow though so be sure
to check back then